[Music]
zeki goes to a restaurant
which has a bumper offer going on but to
get this price
one had to win a simple challenge
whoever won the bumper offer
would get free food throughout the year
if failed
he would have to work in the restaurant
for an entire year
and that too for free tough one right
the challenge read fill the glass
partially with water
with the help of the objects provided
you cannot touch
or move the plate the objects provided
are these
an empty glass a candle a matte stick
a plate filled with water zeki kindly
glanced at the objects that were
provided for some time
and then took up the challenge and guess
what
he won the bumper offer but how did he
win this offer
if you have these things at home why
don't you pause the video and give it a
try
hey this is ganesh here from don't
memorize before we get to the solution
of this riddle
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
first let's take a look at the objects
given now
to get the water inside the glass the
mouth of the glass must be in contact
with water
so the first obvious step would be to
invert the glass
and place it on the plate like this wow
a small amount of water in which the
glass was placed entered the glass
but this is not what we want we need to
fill the glass with a considerable
amount of water
okay wait we do have other objects with
us
maybe that can help candle and match
how do we use them that's right
the first thing we do here is to light
the candle
okay but how will this help us in
getting the water inside the glass
you will be startled to know that it is
this lighted candle
which is the key in getting the water
inside the glass yes
placing this lighted candle in the plate
and then inverting the glass
over it like this should be the setup
after a few minutes you will be able to
see that the candle has extinguished
and the water from the plate has entered
into the glass
this is how zeki backed the bumper price
curious to know how the method works
let's together unfold the mystery
this mystery is nothing else but a
simple science puzzle involving a
concept
which we already know about atmospheric
pressure
which is also called air pressure if you
wish to revise the concept
click on the links given in the
description below
now we have the setup ready okay
so let's get started with the science
behind the puzzle
at first the flame will heat up the air
inside the glass
let me ask you a question here what
happens when the air gets heated up
that's correct the air expands
thus the pressure inside the glass is
more compared to the pressure outside
let me tell you an important fact here
anything in nature
always tends to attain stability or
equilibrium
even the system will so to strike an
the air will move from the high pressure
to the low pressure
in simple words we can say from the
inside of the glass
to the outside that is some of the
expanding
air will escape from under the glass so
as to maintain the equilibrium
also you may be able to notice bubbling
of the water here
we also need to remember a fact that the
flame will not always burn with the same
intensity
once the oxygen inside starts depleting
the flame will start fading off
thus the heat inside will reduce which
will result in the cooling off of the
air inside
the air inside will begin to contract
this contraction creates a low pressure
inside the glass
so where is the high pressure that is
correct
it's outside the glass to summarize
we can say that the pressure inside the
glass is less than
outside thus to create equilibrium
the high pressure air outside tries to
get to the low pressure air inside the
glass
this forces the water into the glass
that's when you notice that the water
has begun to rise in the glass
but slowly once the oxygen in the glass
is completely used up
the flame fades and blows out as the
heating is completely stopped
the expanding air will start to cool
faster
does the pressure inside the glass will
fall considerably
now to maintain the equilibrium the air
moves from the outside to the
inside of the glass quickly forcing the
water into the glass
at a much faster pace hence we see the
water entering inside the glass
rapidly the water will stop entering
once the equilibrium is established
notice the glass now is partially filled
with water
and here we're done with the puzzle
wasn't it interesting
true that here we see that memorizing a
concept
is equivalent to not knowing it for
proper application
we need to understand the concepts well
only then they will be of some use
and at don't memorize we encourage the
learners to understand the concepts
through our crisp yet interesting videos
to become a part of this massive
community of learners do subscribe to
our channel
don't memorize just understand
now before signing off here's another
puzzle for you
note this one may or may not follow the
logic which we just used to solve our
puzzle
here it is now nora also visits the same
restaurant
but now the challenge for the bumper
offer has changed
the objects provided are a box of thumb
tacks matches
and a candle the challenge is to mount
the lit candle to the wall in a way
that the wax does not drip onto the
table or the floor
how would you complete the task share
your answers
in the comments section